let's do it all right I'm gonna be a
little silly all right I'm I let's just
see this are they going to go for a
queen exchange endgame this isn't so bad
it's not so bad be aware don't be scared
the king is a going to find a nice home
on c7 and maybe I could get a night here
at some point so first things first
defend this pawn right if i push the
night I'm just pushing it to a squared
love to go to g5 so I want to watch over
g5 and defend my pawn c6 for two reasons
get my king to c7 and I want to watch
over these two because guess where he's
going to go let's get here right now
there might be a check but I can just
block that with b6 that's not really a
problem Bishop here is a good spot it's
not really a better one or maybe here
maybe I should have considered this I
don't forget about that get about that
one let's go here Casey 7 and what else
let's go here right now which bishop is
my bad bishop you are not able to
identify that start to be able to
identify it let's go here so if you're
still trying to figure it out the answer
is this guy because he's fixed staying
on a dark square these guys obstruct
them so I'd love to have these guys off
the board in other words and then after
the smoke is cleared somehow maybe take
this night out and then end up with the
good night versus let's say a bad bishop
meantime that's a bit of a pain let's
see I was considering a five right there
and what else
ok
let's go here let's roll I want to
weasel my nights around somehow to the
d4 square ok candidate moves for white
what are they gonna be oh you know what
I might want to do I think 93 is like a
definite right where else is that night
going to go ok Knight b6 to this square
I could forget about it but how about
this this is probably good where else
did that night think he was going to go
f4 I'm threatening this right here but
there is possibilities for tactics like
95 or b-five I didn't castle but you
might as well treat this as if we are
castled on opposite sides and this move
right here benefits me because now guess
what square is available the pond is
doing one thing it's no longer doing
another thing what am I talking about
what am I talking about I'm talking
about c5 my night needed a square and he
just got one so I was helped right there
I could have also played there with my
bishop but my bishop is going to get
kicked around if it goes there night a 4
and I don't know if I'm really wanting
to give up my dark square Bishop like
that so the idea here is to now play
Bishop here and get my rook on the D
file hmm
interesting idea a little bit scary I
should probably do something about this
idea of to play a5 a6 because if this
pond flinches that means i can't
maintain upon c6 and if I can't maintain
upon on c6 this night will have access
to d4 you know what I'm talking about
this pond is in directly influencing the
d4 square this is something I touched on
in the video i posted to youtube i can
recall which one it was Magnus Carlsen
versus the world I was talking about him
running his a pond down and influencing
a structure the queenside structure is
really focused on one of the center
squares and I think in the game it was
directed at the did the d5 square excuse
me I think I said D for earlier so
anyhow after all that blabber what am I
talking about here I think it's
important to do this and say you know
what pond you have gone far enough I
don't want to deal with you getting to a
5 because once you're on a five then
you're going to be threatening 86 so let
me just stop you in your tracks right
now so a decision time whenever there is
the possibility for a change in the
structure you had best give things some
serious consideration all right think
twice about the moves you make when you
have the opportunity to change the
structure because how will the remainder
of your pieces be positioned are they
going to be in a good spot let's pile up
on this pond
I don't know if I'm even threatening to
win this I'm assuming the night i'll
move but actually moving the night I'll
get this pod this night isn't this this
night is very very good notice that the
rooks cannot make use of my 7th rank for
as long as this night remains here d 7 b
7 pressure on the center and it really
isn't accessible ok try and get rid of
it now but now I'm picking up this pawn
my night is defended by my bishop and
also my rook right now and running low
on time now so this is a this is a
problem that light square Bishop when
you do this it takes definitely this
recapture so I'm pointing here I do that
if I do this then this pond could maybe
be taken after the night moves and I'm
assuming the night would move here and
then it's very awkward how could I be
annoying to my opponent 9f for Bishop
takes pawn takes Knight d4
interesting Oh what about h 5 night here
Bishop here Wow but this and the night
there so I don't know about that all
right well
and just I'm just going to go away right
now and circulate to this d 7 square I'd
f8 to d7 gotta go faster and maybe I get
in g5 start chasing I could have just
grabbed that pond I could have grabbed
as soon as the night moved oh well ah
it's too fixated on that let's do this
now right now while I can get the other
night up here trade a bunch i'm up to
ponds know this night wasn't doing
anything he came out as soon as I played
f6 he wasn't contributing to the game at
all let's go here more trades bunch of
trades more trades more trades more
trades why not trade pieces I could take
with check if there's a pin okay time
time time time
it's easy to play in a position like
this okay they're down on time good game
Derek let me let me see here let's hit
that rewind button and by the way there
is a I'm not able to see any of the chat
in fact the last the last what
well the last chat message I'm seeing is
from the White Bear 22 who typed no
capital letters rule number one LOL so
yeah
yeah I'm seeing ice ice out Jamie motto
and chest start 69 chest start I did
everything I can I have a message in its
out of my hands at this point so I said
that earlier you might not have been
here um okay so let me hit that back
button there flip and run forward here
ah ok so just keep in mind that there
really isn't a fantastic advantage
running with having blackened castled I
think well I don't know if you should
really even be going for that line I
don't know that black really has very
many problems although I mean you got a
pretty playable position here though
like it's I don't know like what is your
bishop do ok I mean you get in this mmm
I just don't know like what do you what
do you do you throwing your pawns down
here it was an interesting idea this
right here okay well I'm pretty sure you
have to try something else here like
maybe 83 or rook to be one I think you
have to maintain that pond but really my
suggestion is to not even go in for the
Queen trade I don't know I think there's
more to get out of it than just having
black go on castled
ah
so
what can you do instead can be done
instead okay the King takes what about
now what's a better deployment like um
uh here's one thing I mean what sort of
future did your night have if we just
look back I mean look what your night
did move number whatever three or four
whatever he played to f3 I played f6 and
then what did he do for the rest of the
game how many moves were played three
four five six seven something around
here a lot of moves and it was way too
late at this point you're down upon
you're down two ponds and then the night
is moving just to trade off this so he
was boxed out of the game wasn't he
wasn't he boxed out of the game Knight
f3 f6 he's stuck how about you don't do
that here's another thing you can look
into you could look into f4 and then
Knight to f3 it's going to be much
different if the F pond and II pond is
exchanged then you know there's maybe
possibilities for either playing to g5
and then he for look into that the f4
move followed by Knight f3 he's going to
be more active and I'm gonna have to I'm
gonna have to be a bit more cautious
about your king night as I stood in this
game he developed and I took him right
out of the game with f6 he wasn't a
bother for me for pretty much the whole
game so look into that just one early
point if you are in fact going to run
with this look into the f4 Knight f3
stuff again rough thoughts I'm throwing
out there so